[موسيقى]
حزب سياسي يمثل الفكره القوميه التركي
يعرف بمواقفه المتشدده من كل ما يمس
الهويه التركيه يجمع في تعاليمه بين
الهويه التركيه والدين الاسلامي في توليفه
واحده في اطار ما يسمى الاضواء التسعه
التي تؤمن بتوحيد وجهه نظر وطنيه من اجل
حمايه الجمهوريه الحديثه وابعادها عن
المذاهب والانظمه الاداريه الاجنبيه
والراسماليه والليبراليه والشيوعيه
[موسيقى]
اسس الحزب الب ارسلان تركيش في التاسع عشر
من فبراير شباط عام
1969 كان تركيش يؤكد ان حزبه ما كان ليظهر
لولا انحراف حزب الشعب الجمهوري الحزب
السياسي الاقدمي في تركيا عن مبادئ مؤسسه
مصطفى كمال اتاتورك واعلن تركيش في بيانه
الاول ان جمع الاتراك تحت عالم واحد هدف
بعيد المنال ولكنه ممكن مؤكدا ان الحزب
يقدم مصالح الامه التركيه على مصلحه
المجتمع والفرد وان حقوق الفرد وحريته تظل
في المرتبه الثانيه مقارنه بمصلحه
الامهرتو بلندا اجماله
اسلاميه للشركه
احتل الحزب موقعه الجديد في السياسه
التركيه فور تاسيسه بعد ان حصل في
الانتخابات التشريعيه عام
1969 على ثلاثه بالمئه من اصوات الناخبين
واصبح زعيمه تركيش لاول مره نائبا وحيدا
عن الحزب في البرلمان وفي انتخابات عام
1973 ارتفع عدد نواب الحزب في البرلمان
الى ثلاثه فشارك على اثره في حكومه الجبهه
القوميه برئاسه سليمان ديميريل عام
1975 ما جعل منه قوه سياسيه ذات تاثير
فعال
عقب وفاه الب ارسلان
خلفا له في رئاسه الحزب عام
1997 ومعه عاد الحزب ليحقق نصرا جديدا في
انتخابات عام
1999 المحليه واتبع الفوز في العام نفسه
بنصر انتخابي اخر بعد ان حصد
17.98 من اصوات ناخبين ونجم عن انتخابات
1999 تشكيل تحالف حكومي من احزاب الوطن
الام واليسار الديمقراطي والحركه القوميه
الذي حظي ب 12 وزيرا في الحكومه الجديده
احدهم دوله بهشلي بمنصب نائب رئيس الوزراء
لكن مع تفاقم الخلافات في داخل التحالف
الحكومي على وقع الانهيار الاقتصادي في
البلاد
ذهبت تحالف الى انتخابات مبكره اسفرت عن
خروج حزب الحركه القوميه من البرلمان بعد
ني
من الاصوات يدعو الحزب الى تطوير مشروعات
مشتركه مع دول البحر الاسود وحوض بحر
قزوين مثل روسيا وايران ودول البلقان
والشرق الاوسط ويدعم الانتاج المحلي
وتقليل الاعتماد على الموارد الاجنبيه
وتعزيز اقتصاد السوق التنفسي وحمايه صغار
المستثمرين ومحاربه الاقتصاد غير الرسمي
اضافه الى تحديث القطاع الزراعي وتقليل
التبعيه الاجنبيه في الطاقه داخليا دعم
الحزب جهود العداله والتنميه في قضايا
مجتمعيه محوريه في مقدمتها مساء الحكومه
لرفع حظر الحجاب في مؤسسات الدوله وفي
المقابل يؤكد رفضه الهجره غير الشرعيه الى
تركيا ويدعو الى اعاده جميع اللاجئين الى
بلادهم مع الاعتراف بان ذلك لا يكون بين
ليله وضحاها بسبب اتفاقيات موقعه بين
انقره والمجتمع الدولي
سوريا
للحزب على وجوب ان تكون تركيا دوله رائده
في المنطقه اذ يؤمنوا الحزب بضروره هيكله
السياسه الخارجيه من حيث تحديد الاهداف
الاستراتيجيه على اعتبار ان تركيا دوله
نموذجيه في العالم الاسلامي وبامكانها ان
تكون جسرا بين الشرق والغرب ويحرس الحزب
على ايجاد اليات لتحقيق ذلك بتطوير علاقات
ثقافيه وسياسيه واقتصاديه وعسكريه اوسع مع
الكثير من البلدان يرى الحزب ان قبرص من
اهم القضايا الوطنيه لتركيا وان تركيا
ملزمه بتقديم جميع انواع الدعم لشعبها
ويرى ان العلاقات تركيا والاتحاد الاوروبي
ليست مشكله هويه ومصير وان تركيا ليست
مجبره او مدانه او محتاجه الى السير في
فلك الاتحاد الاوروبي ولا يعارض الحزب
الانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي لكنه يطالب
بعضويه مشرفه وليست مذله كما يدافع عن
مبدا المصالح المشتركه مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والالتزام بهذا المبدا
في المجالات الاقتصاديه والسياسيه
والامنيه في 2016 بدات توافق في المواقف
السياسيه بين حزب الحركه القوميه والحزب
الحاكم وفي العام التالي دعم الحزب اقتراح
العداله والتنميه لتحويل نظام الحكم في
البلاد من البرلماني الى الرئاسي وخلال
2018 شكل تحالفا مع حزب العداله والتنميه
عرف باسم تحالف الجمهور دعا على اثره
بهشلي انصاره الى التصويت لمرشح التحالف
اردوغان في الانتخابات الرئاسيه عام 2018
والذي انتهى بفوزه بعد ان حصد 52 ونصف
بالمئه من اصوات الناخبين ليعود ويعلن في
عام 2022 ان مرشح التحالف الانتخابات 2023
هو الرئيس اردوغان داعيا انصار حزبه مره
اخرى الى التصويت له
جمهور اتفاقنا
[موسيقى]